on continue avec les réactions à cette
nouvelle équipe castex troisième
gouvernement
macron l'orangé kobe lee porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir vous avez
rejoint vos côtés gérard onesta
conseiller régional europe ecologie les
verts d'occitanie bonsoir à vous mais
également gérard onesta on commence par
vous l'orangé kobenni que vous inspire
dans sa globalité
ce nouveau gouvernement un nouveau
gouvernement vous êtes optimiste moi je
parlerais de grands recyclage on a
repris les mêmes et on recommence ce qui
veut bien dire que emmanuel macron à
s'entêter dans sa politique
s'entêter dans sa politique de casse
sociale avec la réforme des retraites et
de l'assurance chômage
s'entêter à une politique d'immigration
incontrôlée s'entêter à accepter la
mondialisation qui fait perdre des
emplois en france
non il n'y a rien de neuf sous le soleil
nous avait promis un big bang
on se retrouve avec une tempête dans un
verre d'eau alors bon il ya bien deux
innovations
madame bachelot qui était en manque de
médias on voyait qu'elle courait les
plateaux télé elle aurait sûrement pris
danse avec les stars si on l'avait
proposée elle a pris là le ministère de
la culture on se demande pourquoi
et monsieur dupont moretti alors là
c'est beaucoup plus grave parce que
monsieur dupont moretti
c'est l'homme qui veut lever l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux
dupond moretti c'est l'homme qui veut
interdire le rassemblement national
autant vous dire que l'indépendance de
la justice
et bien c'est pas pour demain et puis
c'est l'homme qui s'est dit honoré et
fier de défendre le frère de mohamed
merah vous voyez on pensait qu'on avait
atteint le pire avec le gouvernement
précédent avec ma prendrai jamais déçu
il ya toujours une étape supplémentaire
vers le choix gérard onesta on va
s'arrêter quelques instants évidemment
on vous interrogera forcément sur ce qui
nous intéresse aussi beaucoup le
ministère de l'écologie met sur eric
dupond moretti c'est vrai que ça a créé
la surprise alors une déclaration de
guerre à la magistrature un new deal lui
et c'est bien le principal syndicat de
magistrats à la fp ça commence un petit
peu mal en tout cas avec ces magistrats
une réaction sur cette nomination pour
le moins surprenante
ils viennent déjà il faudrait dire que
le mécanisme
dénomination des ministres en français
pourrait être perfectible - je voudrais
souligner quelque chose qui n'a été
relevée par aucun commentateur et que
l'ancien vice-président du parlement ou
pérennes que je suis ne peut pas laisser
ce aux sciences en france la nomination
de l'exécutif le fait du prince ou les
dupond moretti il a vu qu'on moretti au
niveau européen les commissaires
européens sont proposés uniquement
proposé au parlement européen qui les
auditionne par écrit par oral longuement
que de tester la compétence d'apprécier
les projets il arrive que les impétrants
soit retoqué là c'est un jeu de chaises
musicales où il faut choyer les uns
rassurer les autres n'ont pas de
ministère à l'autre sans se demander
s'il a moins de compétences derrière on
essaie de capter quelques grandes
gueules ont récupéré de ce soir en
termes de démocratie avancée je pense
qu'on peut quand même imaginer mieux et
moi ça me choque de voir mon pays qui se
targuent d'être des phares de la
démocratie dans le monde fonctionnait
encore en comme ça gérard onesta
c'est pas la première fois ce n'est pas
le fait en tout cas d' emmanuel macron
cesser toute la vème république et son
fonctionnement qu'il faudrait changer
selon vous bien oui on se moque souvent
de la démocratie européenne qui a
également largement perfectible mais au
moins pour désigner l'exécutif si
beaucoup plus transparent et on regarde
kbc des compétences derrière et pas
simplement si on a séduit le prince la
soul est différente république française
c'est toujours le fait du prince en
défaut avec de bonnes surprises
moi je suis jugé puis tout certaine
tendresse pour roselyne bachelot que je
connus par ailleurs et qui a quand même
eu le courage à un moment de l'époque sa
famille politique au moment du pacs et
du mariage pour tous deux s'affirment et
là quand même quelques convictions alors
je ne sais pas c'est la culture c'est
elle s'épanouira est allé pas les droits
des artistes mais pour le coup c'est
peut-être une bonne pioche
toutes les femmes alors on y reviendra
évidemment gérard onesta
laurent jacot belli c'est un
gouvernement qui selon vous est prêt à
mettre sur orbite
emmanuel macron pour 2000
22 mais oui c'est ça en fait la vraie
chose qu'il faut souligner ce soir c'est
que ce gouvernement
finalement ajusté c'est pour écarter
doit edouard philippe qui faisaient
revenons au président de la république
alors on a mis quelqu'un d'un peu plus
ternes en tout cas reçu au ski et
monsieur castex mais on regarde derrière
le même gouvernement c'est un lifting
tout de même des manuels macron de faire
ça parce qu edouard philippe très bien
ressurgir en 2022 face à emmanuel macron
c'est un pari c'est vrai manuel d'un
poids bien compris qu'il fallait qu'il
envoie des signaux aux français qui n'en
pouvaient plus de sa politique qui ne
supporte plus son arrogance et plusieurs
qu'il prend donc il a dit on va faire un
ravalement de façade
la boutique n'attire chalon alors on va
reprendre l'extérieur donc sa peau de
monsieur castex et puis on a dit vous
allez avoir de nouveaux produits
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait c'est
exactement la même chose on reprend les
mêmes et ancien ministre et on les
change de ministère pour certains
derrière on nous dit la même marchandise
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la
mondialisation à outrance la casse
sociale l'immigration bref rien n'a
changé emmanuel macron s'est juste fait
ce soir à lifting à moindre prix mais je
ne pense pas que les français soient
dupes
alors avant d'interroger anomaux gérard
nsa écouter ces quelques réactions
recueillies sur les réseaux sociaux
un gouvernement libéral banal castanet
rb loubet honte de l'intérieur et de la
justice
enfin démissionner darmana et dupond
moretti doivent rétablir la dignité et
l'honneur à la justice est nommé en
militant d'extrême gauche qui souhaite
l'interdiction du rassemblement national
premier parti d'opposition
ça promet si bête et castaner dehors
petit bonheur du soir
pour le reste on reprend largement les
mêmes et on recommence et je m'attends à
une belle pagaille à la justice avec
dupond moretti
de toute façon tous européiste donc zéro
changement possible les français
voulaient changer de politique et garder
le même premier ministre emmanuel macron
a fait exactement l'inversé
il change le premier ministre mais avec
ce nouveau gouvernement
on comprend qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement politique
pas de changement en politique selon
dupont aignan
est-ce qu'il y en aura une selon vous
gérard onesta dans ce qui vous intéresse
le domaine de l'écologie avec la
nomination de barbara pompili leur
barbara c'est une femme de conviction au
pluriel
elle a souvent changé les nommés à la
transition écologique ça lui va bien
elle est toujours en transit et c'est
par les écologistes
elle était ensuite dans un gouvernement
socialiste
maintenant chez makro je pense que son
parcours n'est pas terminée vous savez
en politique il faut choisir son veut
faire son voeu durée elle a décidé elle
de durée nicolas hulot et l'inénarrable
monsieur d'origine et au premier rang
protocolaire est aberrant ministre
d'état ont déjà été rétrogradé ça c'est
pour la place de l'écologie
et surtout nicolas hulot disait que si
bercy ministère des finances n'était pas
en phase avec l'écologie on ne pouvait
rien faire et qui est ce soir le grand
et unique attend désormais de bercy
bruno le maire grand adorateur de la
bagnole et plus grands défenseurs du
nucléaire
autant dire que le match est plié
l'écologie restera décoratifs voilà sens
de la formule de gérard onesta laurent
jacot bd vous partager cette analyse
parce que c'est vrai on l'attendait ce
poste là après l'éclatante voilà
l'éclatant succès des verts aux
municipales et aux européennes un petit
peu avant mais ce gouvernement ne peut
pas être écologiste pour une bonne
raison c'est qu'il croit trop en la
mondialisation ils croient trop au libre
échange sans règles et sans contrôle
pour se soucier d'écologie l'écologie
c'est quoi c'est pas mais qu'il monde en
protéines est électrique et empêcher les
automobilistes d'aller au travail pour
suivre les agriculteurs ou les chasseurs
ça cette icône une écologie le
castratrice et mythique souvent
représentée par les verts
personne n'en veut elle ne serait pas
utile dans la vrai que le gîte c'est
produire près de chez soi
consommer ce qui est produit près de
chez soi d'abord parce que c'est leur
qualité de vie
ça crée des emplois elle puisse tout ça
diminue l'empreinte carbone parce que
les produits ne viennent pas du canada
des états unis de chine
ça ce serait une mesure écologique
intelligente et roland serait lent pour
ans glisseraient pourvoyant d'un vrai
patriotisme économique dont on a tant
besoin
mais évidemment ses frères à la nati
modèle de l'idéologie
libéral gérard on essaie le bouddha fin
parce que c'est vrai qu emmanuel macron
vous avez annoncé un grand changement
avec tombeau tambours et trompettes 1 1
lors de ses discours post co vide qu'est
ce qui va se passer est ce qu'on peut
imaginer un énorme changement on a
entendu déjà jean castex vous prévenir
que la réforme des retraites est bien ce
serait lancé dès l'été le ségur de la
santé a priori on n'a pas changé le
ministre donc ça devrait suivre son
cours qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de
vraiment révolutionnaire pour cette
troisième partie de mandat
mais on se rend compte que ce soir que
le vivier de la macro ni est à sec
et s'ils n'ont trouvé personne pour
essayer de changer les têtes d'affiché
de ce gouvernement en terme de personnel
c'est à sec mais en termes d'idées ça
reste à sec également
on ne change pas un gars de des
ministres même de droite dure parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que monsieur
gérard darmon elles viennent de la
droite c'est assez extrêmes au départ un
dôme m6 s'est recentrée dans ses propos
on connaît on connaît le parcours sur
sur l'économie c'est le libéralisme à
tout crin qui triomphe ce soir quant à
l'écologie radicalement nominaux
girouette n'a pas forcément fait avancer
les hauts lieux merci laurent jacob et
10 ans terminera sur cette jolie formule
merci gérard onesta également d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rtl france